and I will still say this I believe the
reason proper football has the momentum
it has in the U.S besides globalization
besides social media was originally
because of FIFA the video game the
rooftop on a football pitch soccer pitch
with Mr garyvee we call it football too
us Americans have learned proper
football you're messy I didn't realize
you were a football fan I've heard about
you looking and talking I've watched an
actual video of you talking about it's a
great story by the way about wanting to
buy the Jets yes yeah and but I didn't
kind of correlate it up between that
football and this football you know my I
was born in Belarus the former Soviet
Union and my dad
um
was a man that worked all of my
childhood and is also a quiet guy not as
talkative as I am but the one thing he
would talk about all the time was when
the USSR made the final four in the
World Cup when he was a kid and so the
World Cup was a big deal in 86
um uh with Maradona
that finals I watched that with my uncle
and my dad
and so that kind of got me going in 94
it was in the U.S and what's happened in
the states in the last 20 years is
profound I mean the far majority of kids
under 18 in the U.S who are into sports
have a Premier League team
so it's but in 94 it hadn't happened yet
but I went to that World Cup and went to
uh the Italy Ireland match which was a
big one
and so that got me going and then where
it really took off and I will still say
this I believe the reason proper
football has the momentum it has in the
U.S besides globalization besides social
media was originally because of FIFA the
video game oh the game yeah the game I
remember in college we would play Madden
we would play the basketball back then
it was NBA live now it's 2K and FIFA
came out and I bought it and I for Sega
Genesis and I brought it home and all my
friends all my mates were like and then
by a month later it was the only game
everyone was playing and that started
the process so for me the World Cup's a
big big deal I follow it very heavily I
was crushed when the US didn't qualify
for the last one
um uh but American football and the New
York Jets specifically is my deep
passion so much so
that when I got here I had to miss the
opening ceremonies because the Jets were
playing the Patriots and I watched the
game in the hotel room they get beat
like late on in the game they they lost
such a heartbreaker it was just the guy
caught it and ran the hole in for the
field huh with five seconds left in the
game it was 3-3 and he ended the game
and you know for us there are Boogeyman
we haven't beaten the Patriots in 14
matches
and so for seven years because we played
twice a year so yes it's my deep passion
so if anybody who's watching you you
might not know yes imagine there's many
yes
what do you do now what is your main
state of business now I uh I'm an
entrepreneur the two I run two major
businesses right now one is a global
advertising agency so you know if you've
seen the show Mad Men which was a global
phenomenon what are the 2020 to 2023
version of that social media television
all marketing globally uh 2 000 people
around the world APAC UK US Latin Mexico
City uh will eventually expand here into
the Middle East soon uh so that's one
and then over on the other side the
other thing I do full time is uh I
started intellectual property multimedia
brand called V friends which is like a
mix between Pokemon and Sesame Street uh
200 80 characters that I created
launched them as an nft project
now you know executed in collectible
trading cards toys
um animation so building up IP which is
really exciting and you know
the third chapter of my life is the
garyvee of it all where I talk about the
things that I'm passionate about
kindness
competitiveness I call it purple in the
US we've become very polarized between
the blue and the red of the political
parties but I find myself very purple
you know I uh I've been kindness and
being compassionate and
sympathetic are requirements to humanity
at the same token I believe in winning
and building and competing
and so the mix of those two things that
matter to me so you know you know I just
want to go back to marketing and the pr
yes
you're immersed in from a football
perspective yes how can football do more
to kind of amplify the game in the
states
well I think you know some of the stuff
that you and your team have been doing
congrats to you and many others I think
you know
I think that it's happening I think what
can be done more it's all storytelling
at the end of the day this is all
storytelling literally before I flew out
for this trip kid in my office said
man could you imagine Argentina Portugal
and you know what he's referring to is
two superheroes playing against each
other in their final World Cups it's a
dream story stories right Stories the
Fist stories right uh and so I think
that storytelling matters and so you
look at Beckham you look at Ronaldo you
look at mbappe you know just even how
much his story has been told in the
States but there's so many other young
players ironically many on on the
England team that just need more stories
more conversations I think trading cards
and stickers have been huge the US is
very much into collecting
cards obviously they're in in proper
football it's normally stickers that's
been huge that's been the guy I'll see
you does that
who is your Meek Mill Meek Mill's into
it
buster
there's a another Jewish guy a white guy
oh Eric W
um nonetheless there's a lot of
personalities doing a ton of uh I've
done a ton with the trading cards the
video games the documentaries look at
formula one I mean F1 was I you couldn't
find an American talking about formula
one five years ago if you looked for
them and paid someone to talk about it
one Netflix execution and you know I
hear about Max and Hamilton once a week
in random conversations and so you know
I think it's storytelling you know and I
think I think proper football I actually
would argue that football has done as
good of a job I would say mixed martial
arts I would say basketball but those
are the global Sports now
crazy because I mean
the American Sports is just so powerful
within America and they're trying to
globalize their games as well I come in
here yes I was part of the the thinking
of that with
I don't need a premier league but man
united the team I played yes used to
come to the states
the owners
were Americans that's right all that
commercialization that's right that's
right growing the brand but you always
felt like it just wasn't sticking but I
get again there's a World Cup coming
and that's going to be really important
and I think us as a brand as well five
are going to be making a real good push
to kind of come into that market you
know again when you grow up in Europe
any interest in America even today
seems quite small when you're when
you're an American the interest is so
much greater than it was a decade ago
that it feels like it's sticking
um I do think the world company America
is obviously Canada Mexico is going to
be
a profound moment but look I think if
you go back to two and three World Cups
ago even making the round of 16
captured America's attention the ratings
on those matches were enormous
you know I'd like to think as an
American that it's going to happen in my
lifetime where that team comes along
and the interest at the Young level is
so much greater and you do have kids who
are six and seven
the LeBron James of the world the
DeAndre Hopkins these freak athletes I
do believe more of them are considering
football than American football than
than basketball and you're going to get
the right group of two or three kids
that eventually are going to time you
said it before we went on air it's
timing if we in America if we get the
right two or three kids to choose
football instead of the other
Alternatives at the right time at the
same time
and capture the right moment you get a
final four you get a finals in the U.S
in the World Cup in the next 20 years I
think you'll see America continue with
it so I mean even even the MLS is a far
healthier league today than many of us
thought they could ever be 20 years ago
and so and you see Christian playing at
the highest levels like
there's just too many people there's too
much money there's too much ambition
there's too much American bravado it
just feels like it's an inevitable and
and I think a final four team would take
it I mean again for my father to
continuously
bring up that one the only USSR yeah
England same right I mean you know like
that's exactly it was the same World Cup
it was both 66 for both of them
it's amazing to me that for a half a
century like a half a century later you
can have so many people in England and
in the former Soviet Union
continue to talk about something that
happened in 1966. so I think that's what
America is looking for its final four
run
but I couldn't leave without speaking to
you about
If You Is Us yes yes
we've got a four year run now yes
going to America what would be your key
three or four steps I would bet the
Forum on short form content and the
algorithms so I would have an American
plan for your content which I think
you've done incredibly well but
specifically for the states for Tick
Tock YouTube shorts
that is a battleground of awareness I
would also be very aggressive in doing
JVS like this reaching out to the top
podcasts in culture the Mr beasts the
Charlie demilios and everybody and
everybody below that and do as much
collaboration as possible I would Lean
Into The Gamers I really do think the
FIFA you know Gamers is a on YouTube and
twitch is a huge audience
um and I would be present it's a good
time of year with the way that leagues
work between premier league and MLS it
gives you the opportunity to be in the
state's off cycle and I think that's an
important road but I think it's a
culture and the sport itself and this
you know it's fun to say this to you
because you've already executed it it's
more content more content more right
it's it's just like shots on goal yeah
yeah like just keep putting shots reps
keep putting shots on goal and so I
think the more content you can produce
for the channels that matter in the
states and the individuals and the media
platforms that matter in the states some
I think some JVS some Partnerships with
you know the bar stools the 137 PMS the
different media Outlets complex and so I
think there's a lot of opportunity so
what are you doing here though I mean
you love football obviously have you got
anything planned what's your plans just
some meetings with some of the local
entrepreneurs and business people but
the plans have been to absorb as much
football as possible you know the timing
worked out nice back to you know no
different than I always like
living the things that I talk about so
if I'm going to sit here and tell you to
make the commitment to the US and and
the road for me when I saw the schedule
and I saw formula ones last weekend in
Abu Dhabi and World Cup Opening you know
and I could squeeze it in right before
Thanksgiving which is a hair quieter
these this Monday Tuesday which is
normally a lot of stress for me a little
quieter because of Thanksgiving it just
kind of was a perfect storm and I made
the commitment to to make to put in the
work and get out here and uh and I'm
glad I did
enjoy it but also when we spoke about
earlier your team your passion for the
Jets I've watched this video man the
passion and the story was just like well
it's only a matter of time before this
guy buys his Club but I looked at the
value of the club is four billion
dollars if you've got four billion
dollars you're standing of me there's a
problem
purchasing the Jets you know my plan is
pretty simple I've done very well
investing but I think I'm going to
operate these two very enormously large
companies they're both already pretty
big boys and if I do that for the next
15 years properly I think that puts me
in Striking Distance and then like
anything you just we talked it's yes
it's definitely that but you know I
think I've got to build well through the
two companies that I have the biggest
equity in which is be friends and
vaynerx
um and then it's going to be similar to
what we talked about this the theme of
this whole conversation it's timing if
I'm fortunate enough to be in a place of
wealth creation that maps with when the
club becomes available then Destiny
played out and if not to be very Frank
um I'm just enjoying the process of
trying
the process of trying to achieve such a
big goal is incredibly fulfilling and uh
of course I would be disappointed
especially if I was dangerously close
and lost the bid to somebody but I I can
only control what I can control and
that's what I focus on good just um as
well as social media yes obviously
pays up your life yes
yes I'll just finish making like a
three-part docky series for um Amazon
yes and it was around football and
sexuality and football
mental health and football racism in
football yes
the key pillars in all of the three
episodes was the impact of social media
yeah and the negative edits that that
can surround it and that kind of the
negative impact it can have on these
athletes yes
again where do you stand on social media
in that sense
I stand on social media the way I stand
on religion the way I stand on
traditional media the way I stand on
parenting
I believe that social media is an
amplifier of the truth that's within
someone
you know obviously the days of 2006 to
2010 or over where we all spent all our
time talking about the greatness of
social media it was connecting the world
it allowed Americans to fall in love
with proper football we've got to meet
people we now are spending our time
talking about the negativities of social
media social media are empty pipes
Tick Tock and YouTube and Facebook and
Twitter these are empty pipes
I think that
what social media is doing is exposing
humans truth
I think that if everybody who's watching
Reign out chose to see all the beauty
in social media they would find it I for
example on my birthday just 10 days ago
decided to find 15 different gofundme's
and contribute to them share them with
my audience and we profoundly affected
15 different families lives in one
minute
on the flip side as you know you know a
footballer I mean look what happened in
England in that championship match I
watched it by the second
so both sides of humanity show up in
social media because it's empty these
are empty pipes that humans fill I don't
believe that social media is doing
anything other than showing us the truth
I don't think the algorithm makes you a
racist I think you're a racist that's
exposed by the algorithm and so I think
we're in this period right now where
we're going through it I believe it's
actually one step backwards two steps
forward I think the exposing of some of
our human shortcomings are actually
going to allow us to address it and so
for me I view social media as a net
positive I think it's painful right now
but I think we need to have a very
substantial conversation in the world
about modern parenting
I think parents need to be parents need
to be accountable you know like putting
your hands up that's not the parents we
grew up with or our parents grew up with
I also think parents need to focus on
self-esteem building I mean I get hate
every single day and I meet that with
compassion for the other person and I
mean that when somebody leaves Gary
you're a blowhard you're full of crap
you're not as good as you think you are
you're bananas when I see those comments
and much much worse when I see those
comments I don't feel bad about myself I
feel compassion and empathy that someone
is hurting so much that they're trying
to tear me down is that because you're
built a certain way that's right
that's right it's because that's right
my circumstances my parenting and thus
that is my message if you're a parent
that deeply loves your child and you're
so scared of tick tock or Twitter maybe
you should focus on building their
self-esteem and holding them accountable
instead of blaming everybody besides
yourself and so I think accountability
you know it's funny I mentioned the
friends there's a character I created a
countable aunt
and it is emerging as my favorite
character of all my characters and that
is because I genuinely believe that if
we become more accountable
that the world would be a much happier
place and so if you're a parent watching
right now and you're so mad at Instagram
delete it from your child's phone but
you don't want them to be upset with you
maybe you should decide that being your
friend's child your child's friend is
not more important than being your
child's parent and so once we lean into
accountability and stop blaming
everything governments people platforms
and we start looking at what we can
control
I think we can have a much better world
could you uh do you don't feel that any
they do need help from the platform they
do need help from governments and
legislation for instance there's new
platforms coming out and I don't maybe
have different ways of looking at it and
battling with the in terms of
verification yeah I I look I believe
that governments have a seated table I
have I believe that entrepreneurs have a
seat at the table
I I've never struggled with the concept
of let governments regulate that's fine
uh but governments have regulated
alcohol governments have regulated
Firearms that's right we have to get
into a bigger conversation
and that conversation is how are we
parenting what are our value systems can
we tune out the outside noise and so I'm
as an entrepreneur as a business person
I'm pro-government involvement I'm fine
whatever the governments want to decide
we'll navigate around but I'm telling
you once we take this on our table
as parents as Elder silver I'm an oldest
child as oldest siblings as humans
as people of platforms you know one of
the things one of the reasons I said yes
to this is I think you're spewing
positivity and I think people that are
happy
and people that see it right now
negativity is quite loud I believe the
people that are happy
and have joy have a responsibility to
get louder and that's why I produce the
content I produce every single day in
the face of a negative world that comes
with judgment for your positivity
might choose to get louder and I think
people that are happy and positive need
to do the same I love that I love it
let's line it up
I know you want the USA men's team I do
I do want that unfortunately I'm gonna
have to let you down and it's not going
to happen I understand I understand
maybe in the four years we've got a
better chance but who do you think
realistically is going to win the World
Cup I'm this weird vibe towards Spain
wow yeah I think Spain is being slept on
a little bit
um
that's who I've been going with the
whole time
um I like most football fans around the
world I'm Dreaming for Argentina
Portugal as a final
I mean I couldn't
of course by the way actually I if I had
my choice I I'm I actually have a lot of
you know I was really disappointed that
England and the US ended up in the same
group because I actually have a lot of
love towards England you know I back to
it's been such a long time back to being
a passion back to our incredible
relationship with that beautiful country
and so I would love to see England get
there I have a weird feeling that
Spain's gonna make a real run and then
as I mean I couldn't even imagine
couldn't even imagine
how many people would watch Portugal
Argentina
in a final that would be one of the
great Sports stories of the of the last
hundred years and so there's definitely
a part of me Romancing that final
Portugal versus Argentina breaks the
culture the whole world the whole world
thank you for having me my friend good
luck such a pleasure cheers thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]